Vision Pro is here let's unbox
[Music]
it oh my goodness I like its little
protective hat it's perfectly like it
doesn't move it doesn't go
anywhere check that out look at it the
future is in my hands right now now
inside here is our dual band loop it's
kind of just like a Big Apple watch band
but for your head USBC cable we've got
the battery pack and this is the little
connector and we've got a charging brick
what's in here a polishing cloth I
haven't seen a sticker
yet this is the extra light seal cushion
that they give you so here's everything
that comes in the Apple Vision Pro box
we've got our headset external battery
pack charging brick USBC cable polishing
cloth extra light seal the solo knit
band and the Dual Band Loop